I've decided that the children on the
Isle of the lost be given a chance to
live here and over it on Haven can you
ask your parents what happened to the
rest of the Royal Disney family there
are some princes and princesses we
missed in the first three descendants
movies we know that you get along with
everyone even the villain kids so show
the rest of the Disney characters and
love there's plenty of room in the
castle for more ball gowns and fabulous
hats and we would love to see more
royalty sentence Dancing with the vks we
love to The Descendants movies but a few
famous characters were missing from the
storylines and we think that was a
missed opportunity for more fun at
auradon here are the Disney characters
that fans wish for in descendants 3
watch until the end to find out which
Lost Boys son would have been friends
with Harry hook Arielle and melody Ariel
and Prince Eric are a gorgeous couple
fans would have loved to see them at
auradon and Arielle and Eric's daughter
melody would have been an awesome
addition to Aragon crap just think of
how melody could have helped model
defeat Emma and descendants to do to her
mermaid heritage melody is an amazing
swimmer she could have beaten Emma in a
swimming contest on top of that she can
speak with and understand the kwatak
creatures she can also create waves in
the ocean that's a pretty cool trick if
now I needed a friends with her kwatak
abilities in d2 and d3 which she did
melody would have been perfect mother
Gothel and rapunzel during an interview
with 17 dove Cameron reveals something
interesting she said if she wasn't cast
as Maleficent's daughter in the sentence
movies she would like to be mother
Goethals daughter because i love well
except for the whole neglecting her in
the tower parts dog points out that all
the villain parents are pretty
neglectful but she still loves those
Disney villains daf has always been a
fan of Mother Gothel what's not to love
sure she's manipulative and evil but she
knows how to get what she wants
mother Gothel might be wicked but she's
not the worst Disney villain out there
while she did kidnap and lock Rapunzel
in a tower
she didn't send us a baby to perish on
the eve of her 16th birthday there's a
fan theory on reddit that Rapunzel and
Cassandra from tangled the series are
half sisters the theory states that
Prince Frederick of Corona had an affair
with a commoner before he met and
married Queen Ariana and had Rapunzel he
had a baby girl with this commoner but
unfortunately the mother didn't make it
through the birth Prince Frederick hid
the motherless child and went on to
marry his Queen Ariana
together they had Rapunzel and the rest
is Disney history if dogs played the
role of mother Gotham's daughter she
could have been related to Rapunzel and
Cassandra
they wouldn't have been technically
blood-related but it would have made for
a weird mesh of pseudo siblings just
imagine the power they would have had
working together to get maleficent
sector back from the queen of meme and
speaking of working together you'll
never believe what unlikely friendship
could potentially happen if descendants
forever becomes a reality keep watching
to find out Alice in Wonderland fans
loved the idea of Alice in Wonderland
making an appearance in the dissonance
films one fan thought Alice and the Mad
Hatter would have made for a rather
interesting parents at Oregon just think
of all the missed opportunities instead
of an enchanted forest there could have
been a magical Wonderland on the
outskirts of Oregon now her crew could
have received cryptic clues from the
Cheshire Cat
can you imagine dude the dog talking to
the Cheshire Cat hands down the Mad
Hatter should have organized the family
Day celebration at our time trap Alice's
daughter Allie would have been a fun
addition to the Aragon prep crew Holly
is quite curious just like her mother
and she's always up for a wild adventure
too she could have helped get to the
bottom of that sleep spell Audrey placed
on the kingdom Allie is also eccentric
and energetic this would have helped her
to fit right in with the villain kids
she's the kind of girl who would
immediately accept mouths Evie and the
rest of the gang into her circle of
friends Anastasia's daughter we all know
that Drizella is the MA
a busy Tremayne but for some reason
dizzy was raised by her grandmother
instead of her mother Gisela and
Anastasia don't make an appearance
throughout the descendants movie it's
thought we would have loved it if dizzy
was best friends with Anastasia's
daughter after all Drizella and
Anastasia were so close it seems weird
that their children wouldn't be dizzy
and Anna would have been the best
cousins ever Peter Pan raise your hands
if you would have liked to see Peter
Pan's son in the descendants movies
we're dying to see that we imagine Peter
Pan's son to be mischievous and clever
he would probably run a smuggling ring
to get goods to the Pirates on the Isle
of the Lost
we know that Peter Pan is not a big fan
of pirates especially Captain Hook the
Peters always been a rebel at heart
which means his son would probably
follow in his rebellious footsteps do
you think Peter Pan's son would be
friends with Captain Hook's son Harry
that would be wild
it could happen if descendants four gets
green-lighted maybe we can ask
Tinkerbell to fly Peter and his son to
Aragon
are there any Disney characters you
wanted to see in descendants three if
you said is four were to happen which
new characters would you want to be in
the film let us know in the comments
subscribe to the things and give this
video a big thumbs up thanks for
watching we'll see you later
[Music]